daniel paillé est administrateur de
sociétés autrefois premier
vice-président aux investissements
privés de la caisse de dépôt de
n'éveiller bonsoir bonsoir
quel regard vous portez quel bilan vous
faites du travail de mike aussi bien
depuis dix ans quand il est arrivé
premièrement ça a été une surprise
sa nomination les personnes qui le
voyait venir vous venez de mentionner
des candidatures éventuelles mais lui
était pas du tout sur la carte et il y
avait eu deux ou trois présidents très
rapide qui a va passer là et donc il
fallait une stabilité puis vous venez de
dire en 2009 quand est arrivé c'était
suite à la crise financière de 2008
à l'aller les grosses banques qui ont
fait faillite en juin aux états unis et
les fameux pca de la caisse dont il y
avait une dévaluation de 40 milliards
alors donc quand c'est arrivé ça pouvait
pas les pires
donc quand tu arrives dans une situation
comme ça tu prends l'ascenseur
bon il le prix très bas et en plus
l'embellie
on sait depuis dix ans l'économie va
très bien partout donc il fait beau il y
en a profité mais en même temps il a
apporté de la rigueur la stabilité il
fallait quelqu'un de très calme très
bons les deux pieds sur terre puis je
pense qu'on doit reconnaître puis de 9
points 9 % de rendement annuel
oui à de moyenne et une diversification
que je dirais pas seulement techniques
ou théorique parce qu'avant diversifiée
en obligations actions hypothèque un peu
d'immeubles
c'était sa diversification alors que ce
qu'il a fait c'est qu'il y avait les
moyens de prendre un certain nombre de
risques on pense aux oem ou une pratique
à vancouver avec le train qu'ils ont de
l'aréopage au centre ville donc il ya
créé je peux dire une diversification
original aujourd'hui on mentionnait à la
caisse que 64% des actifs de la caisse
en 2009 est investi au canada 64% et
aujourd'hui 2018 64 % des actifs sont
investis à la croissance des marchés
mondiaux
donc vraiment c'est devenu une
institution internationale monsieur
c'est bien quand est arrivé s'est fixé
trois objectifs et su retourner dans son
rapport annuel son premier rapport
annuel
le dit qu'est ce que je veux faire je
veux avoir des gens compétents autour de
moi ultra qu une équipe exceptionnelle
qui s'est fait notamment renault lescure
qui était le candidat que vous avez pas
mentionné ce soir mais possiblement qui
sera pas candidat c'est christian dubé
essai en double il faut pas l'oublier il
était à laquelle j'ai décidé de
retourner en politique bon il offre un
petit pincement au coeur
ce soit et ils voulaient aussi monsieur
c'est bien avoir une reconnaissance
internationale
et puis faire en sorte que les
québécoises et québécois soient fiers
qui a une confiance envers la caisse et
s'assure les trois points il a très bien
réussi et la diversification mais la
caisse c'est plus gros la caisse de
dépôt c'est presque l'équivalent des
caisses desjardins en termes d'actifs
c'est un peu plus gros que la banque
nationale
alors c'est sûr que moi quand j'étais là
avec jean campeau de cette époque les 9
90 92 l'actif était dix fois moins te
prendre 4 milliards alors c'est sûr qu'à
34 milliard en moins de place et on
était particulièrement au québec et au
canada mais à 320 milliards il faut de
l'espace et donc il y en a il a changé
le visage de l'institution de la caisse
doit changer le visage de l'institution
et je dois dire que il a bien fait tout
en gardant la caisse avec des bons
investissements québec il ya pas oublier
le québec
ah bon est ce qu'on peut faire davantage
réponse oui par rapport aux pme par
exemple par rapport au démarrage
d'entreprises saut dans les milieux on
dit souvent kakese un peu trop gros pour
un sommet ont pris les moyens pour
diversifier
bon alors vous avez mentionné la banque
nationale le grand patron de la banque
nationale c'est louis vachon
son nom circule beaucoup pour succéder à
michael c'est bien est ce que c'est ce
que vous entendez qui croyez vous
remplacer ma course et bien je pense que
la pire chose qui doit arriver aux
personnes qui voudraient être président
de regeneron de la caisse c'est de voir
son nom aujourd'hui mentionné quelque
part cela sa loi vendredi non non non
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut de la
compétence le ministre le dit mais il
faut aussi la capacité de le faire
il faut être en train de il faut avoir
le défi il faut avoir le goth excusez
l'expression pourrait faire puis aussi
de savoir relever des défis et de bien
comprendre de québec et le processus de
sélection est amorcé donc le conseil
d'administration est à la recherche mais
c'est le gouvernement qui doit pour vous
sait où et de la loi dit très bien que
c'est le conseil qui propose aux wikis
adopte pour le président andré temps
général et le gouvernement vont lui dire
oui ça c'est correct
est ce que c'est un odieux un choix ça
appartient au conseil de la caisse
le président du conseil de la caisse
cependant ça c'est une gouvernement
qu'il nomme et il est heureux de voir
que parce que monsieur tessier président
du conseil de l'a15 est arrivée en même
temps que monsieur c'est bien et en
termes de gouvernance d'entreprises ou
de sociétés comme ça c'était pas
nécessairement bonne idée que de
remplacer les deux têtes dirigeantes
dans le mémo we love présentement
monsieur sebia par un an plus tôt que
prévu après 10 ans se bat grecque
et puis après il y aura une transition
heureuse et douce sans doute qu'on vous
suive de près daniel paillé merci
beaucoup merci merci